g j'ai débuté que chabrol dans un double
tour et je me suis fait traiter de deux
chargeurs d'acteurs qui ne ferait jamais
rien qui n'arriverait jamais à rien vu
que jamais rien du tout finalement ce
rôle m'a bien aidé moi de me raconter
belmondo c'est insensé avant de faire
une grande des scènes d'émotion à
continuer là dans dix ans tourne et rats
qui se met à pleurer et oui mais ça et
je veux dire j'ai toujours fait ça et
quand j'étais au conservatoire ne
prenait pas au sérieux parce que j'étais
décontracté on a toujours reproché à
l'art mais aussi à l'or mais je m'en
fous je voulais pas faire de carrière
dans l'armée mais au théâtre et au
cinéma même maintenant me veut je débute
un film je vois les gens très inquiet
parce que je tire pas des grands propos
sur mon rôle beaucoup d'acteurs dit je
l'exercé pas suffisant je vais trop de
choses je vais être metteur en scène où
on se lance dans la politique à tout va
pour montrer qu'on est con et très
profond mais je trouve que de faire le
but c'est déjà pas mal mais c'est une
belle distraction et moi j'aime beaucoup
ce qu'ils veulent c'est de jouer pour
autre chose